I think people are fascinated by the
psychic dimension or the paranormal
because it represents it's a metaphor
for what more might be possible and I
don't think it's inherently where the
answer lies for us you know that our
possibilities for humanity lies in
psychic abilities but I think it's a
metaphor for that other things are
possible that things are deeper than
they appear on the surfers that there's
a lot more and that's why it's always so
fascinating that's why also in times of
crises people sometimes go back to their
there you know it's an easy place to
look for deeper meaning or higher
possibilities or greater possibilities
and you know it's not necessarily where
we'll find it but it's it's the first
place one of the first places to look
I don't feel that people are explained
pressing more I mean when I perform it's
you know it's it's it it impacts people
people have strong reactions to it so I
don't feel that people's responses as
has differed there's perhaps new
opportunities that are opening up
because maybe because there's more
interest in in the in media but from
people themselves I haven't felt a
difference
people are rarely scared by what I do
occasionally I've had somebody be caught
off guard and get upset because they
just just couldn't understand it and
they and they showed it visible you know
kind of response that's rare because I
also approached what I do in a very
light-hearted way it's a playful kind of
mess with your mind kind of quality I
think it's more when something just
unexpected happens that's what's most
shocking for people and I can pop up at
any point during my performance is like
it's completely unexpected and that's
what catches people and makes them all
of a sudden kind of step back and go
what did that really happen what did I
just see so it's more the unexpected
component rather than as a specific
thing that I do there was one time where
I performed a miracle but because it
wasn't a bit because it was kind of
expected it hardly had any impact and
then I remember a few seconds later
doing something more simple and then
realizing that it had a much bigger
impact and I was like
you